فيروس
يفترض ان تكون هناك كلمه ربما بعد هذا
الابلاء بالصوت لرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
كنت اتحدث عن ان الشباب هم فئه مهمه في
هذه الانتخابات ايضا هناك
الاتراك المقيمون في الخارج خارج تركيا
يبلغ نسبتهم اكثر من 5%
من الناخبين هذا اللقاء يجري رئيس تركيا
الان
جيكي
ان شاء الله
وزير الداخليه
بانه كل الامور تسير بسلاسه ليس هناك اي
مشكلات المسار مستمر حتى الان المهم هنا
طبعا
فيما يتعلق بالاقتراع في مناطق الزلزال
المنكوب مواطنين انا هناك
بمحبه كامله يبدون اصواتهم حتى في تلك
المناطق ليس هناك اي مشكلات
واتمنى بانه بعد فرز الاصوات لشعبنا
ولديمقراطياتنا ان شاء الله
اطلب من الله تعالى بان يكون كل الخير
للشعبنا
يطلب من كل المواطنين بان يريدون باصواتهم
حتى مساء اليوم هذا مهم جدا من ناحيه اطار
القوه الديمقراطيه في تركيا وايضا من هنا
انا اقدم كل المسؤولين وكل الذين موجودون
الان في مراكز الاختراع شكرا لهم
مركز الاقتراح حيث ادلى رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وزوجته بصوتيهما في اسطنبول نعم
قبل لحظات وما يغادران مركز الاقتراع الذي
تجمع امامه عدد من الناخبين ربما وهذه
هتافات نسمعها
[تصفيق]